[Musique]
bonsoir à tous
quand on m'a demandé quand les
organisatrices orienté en main dit de
parler de la rupture je me suis dit mais
ils sont complètement fous un sujet
comme ça c'est immense et un sujet sur
l'agroalimentaire c'est encore plus
difficile alors rapidement à la rupture
c'est une idée un concept complètement
nouveau qui va changer votre vie qui
peut même la perturber profondément ça
peut être un produit ça peut être un
service app est une oeuvre une oeuvre
collective une oeuvre artistique
en tout cas c'est quelque chose qui va
modifier durablement est définitivement
un autre de vie quand par exemple
l'ordinateur le téléphone portable alors
j'aurais pu vous parler de tonnes
d'exemples de produits à venir en
agroalimentaire qui pourrait être
l'occasion d'ailleurs de rupture
important dans deux modes de vie et j'ai
préféré pour aborder la rupture sous un
angle différent
la rupture en termes de rupture dans la
rupture
je m'explique et c'est un goût que j'ai
particulièrement pour avancer à contre
courant il est bon parfois de s'opposer
à certaines choses qui semblent
inévitables et qui ne souffre d'aucun
débat et je vais vous propose de faire
un débat sur des objets qui semble
n'avoir aucun possibilité de débat alors
cette idée m'est venue d'un livre qui
est sorti très récemment
c'est un livre au départ de sarah
shulman sur la gentryfication d esprit
de l'unification of mind et qui parle en
fait de les changements à new york
notamment dans la communauté gaie avec
des habitants d'un quartier populaire
qui se sont vu d'abord déloger d'un
point de vue économique mais aussi tout
un esprit très entreprenant très
innovant qui s'est fait remplacer par
des mentalités beaucoup plus conformiste
et je me suis posé la question est ce
que les réformes qu'on nous annonce dans
l'agroalimentaire dans l'agronomie et
l'alimentaire ne sont elles pas
objet aussi d'une forme de
gentrification est-ce qu'on n'oublie pas
certains concepts de base ou une partie
de la population
alors je vais m'appuyer sur trois choses
qui sont des changements annoncés et
probablement peu discutable le circuit
court l'agroécologie et l'alimentation
industrielle qui semble être la pire des
choses qu'on puisse offrir à l'humanité
en termes d'alimentation alors je vais
m'intéresser d'abord pour commencer au
cirque les cours alors les circuits
courts c'est quoi c'est éviter qu'un
camion se balade dans toute l'europe ou
voir dans le monde entier et qu'il
alimente un circuit de distribution très
long très coûteux en énergie est passé
par des circuits beaucoup plus court
alors il semblerait que ça permette un
gain a priori de pouvoir d'achat aux
consommateurs il semblerait que on offre
des revenus accrus à l'agriculteur il
semblerait qu'on offre là que la
possibilité de création d'emploi local
et enfin on aura un impact très
important sur l'environnement
sans remettre en cause la validité de
pas mal de concepts je m'intéresserai en
particulier sur le dernier point qui est
l'impact environnemental alors j'aurais
pu vous prendre comme exemple par
exemple ici la suède avec les tomates
suédoise ou les fraises décosse et
j'aurais pu vous démontrer à l'aide de
publications scientifiques
on a démontré qu'il était plus
intéressant d'apporter des tomates
d'espagne que de produire des tomates en
suède ou d'importer des fraises d'italie
puis plutôt que de consommer des fraises
écossaise vous allez me dire c'est un
peu caricatural vous prenez un exemple
très 7,30 rio nal alors du coup je vous
propose de rester entre le 48e nord de
latitude et le quarante septième lors
alors ça correspond entre reims et bonin
voyons d'à peu près deux dents et on va
commencer par l'autriche et je vais
rester sur ma tomates pourquoi parce que
c'est un fruit légume qui est
probablement le fruit légume préféré au
monde on a du mal à s'en passer on
retrouve partout et sous toutes les
formes
et je vous montre un premier c'est alors
que c'est le fruit d'une publication
très récente en 2014 voilà vous avez
dans agronomique sustainable
development' et on voit que un circuit
très court 1 6 km de la zone de de
consommation dans une agriculture ultra
moderne en serres chauffées sur substrat
artificiel on a un impact de
réchauffement climatique en éteignant
co2 qui est bien supérieur à des tomates
importées d'italie ou d'espagne
alors effectivement si on regarde
effectivement l'agriculture biologique
d'une tomate produit en plein été en
cernant chauffer en autriche on a
effectivement un impact environnemental
en termes de capacité de réchauffement
climatique est très faible mais regardez
bien l'exemple italien il est assez
marquant si vous regardez en bleu en
bleu c'est l'emballage en fait
l'emballage des tomates italiennes c'est
celle qui apporte le plus d'impact
environnemental mais si vous enlevez le
l'emballage extraordinairement coûteux
et que vous comparez uniquement l'aspect
transport et l'aspect agricole vous
voyez que l'écart n'est pas si
extraordinaire et ceux pourtant malgré
1600 km de voyage des tomates en plaçant
italienne donc en fait cette analyse
c'est pour vous montrer qu'il faut faire
très attention
le circuit court oui mais ça dépend de
quoi du mode de production ça dépote des
emballages si vous faites du circuit
court mais vous emballez avec des
emballages extrêmement coûteux si vous
faites un mode de culture qui n'est pas
effectivement attentif a notamment à la
dépense énergétique vous allez vous
trouver dans les circuits courts qui
n'est en fait pas du tout intéressant
alors on va prendre maintenant un
exemple français qui est l'alimentation
de vache pour la production de lait
alors c'est un exemple qui a été cet
exemple il vient de collègues
d'agroparistech ont publié en 2009 dans
ce journal que les neuf productions et
ils ont démontré que et pour l'impact de
réchauffement climatique en équivalent
co2 produit et pour la signification des
pluies en équivalent de dioxyde de
soufre alimenter des vaches pour
produire du lait avec du soja importé du
brésil a un impact environnemental
inférieur à des tourteaux de soja
faute des tourteaux de colza par non
importé produit en france
donc ces deux exemples vous montrer que
quand on parle de circuits courts
il faut pas uniquement regarder le
transport qui effectivement un coût
énergétique
il faut regarder globalement l'ensemble
des dépenses est effectivement la
manière dont vous produisez peut avoir
des impacts considérables en termes de
changements climatiques le deuxième
aspect dont je vous parlais c'est la
grille cologie l'agroécologie c'est
quelque chose qui est inévitable en
termes de santé publique en termes de
santé environnementale et pourtant là
encore on peut engager un certain débat
la vase la vision dont certains
politiques ont de l'agro écologie et la
manière dont elle est retranscrite dans
les grands médias est une manière qui me
semble très discutable et auquel il faut
ramener quelques données importantes
pour comprendre qu'on ne peut pas faire
n'importe quel agroécologie alors la
première chose dont je vais vous montrer
c'est tout de même c'est voilà ce qu'a
apporté l'agriculture moderne
elle a permis en allemagne par exemple
si sur cet exemple qui est un des
données tirées de l'iphone la food and
agriculture organization
elle a permis de multiplier par deux les
rendements de blé en allemagne en france
et en angleterre
et si je vous montre ce résultat c'est
pour vous montrer derrière un autre fait
c'est que dans le monde on n'a cessé de
voir et en pourcentage c'est des courbes
grise et en nombre de populations on n'a
cessé de voir reculer la faim dans le
monde et donc il faut bien se rappeler
que la performance agricole c'est
d'abord un outil de lutte contre la faim
dans le monde
cette faim dans le monde elle est loin
d'être terminée si vous regardez ces
chiffres en afrique
alors certes en pourcentage en gris on
voit la proportion de population de
moins en moins en proportion
mais en nombre on a de plus en plus de
gens qui sont affamés et en océanie du
north vous excluez l'australie et la
nouvelle zélande vous avez des gens qui
sont plus en plus nombreux à manquer en
alimentation et je vous en ai encore un
autre élément de réflexion pour vous
dire attention quand on parle d'agrico
logis à ne pas perdre cette idée de
performances agricoles
si vous regardez des chiffres de la fao
en 1960 on était
deux humains pour un hectare arabe en
gros chaque humain sur terre disposés
d'à peu près un demi hectare pour se
nourrir en 2007 on disposait plus que de
même pas un quart d'hectare et en 2050
on disposera encore de beaucoup moins
d'hectares 0 18 hectares par humain
alors quand vous parlez d'une
augmentation de la population mondiale
que vous parlez d'une diminution daniel
la surface arable
rapporté au nombre d'habitants sur terre
vous ne pouvez pas engager un débat sur
l'agroécologie sans vous préoccuper de
la performance agricole et je vais vous
montrer un modèle qui probablement n'est
pas forcément très viable c'est une
publication très récente de 2017 dans
pns alors pns pour une idée pour ceux
qui ne connaissent pas ce jeu c'est
journal
c'est la revue de l'académie des
sciences américaine c'est un journal en
termes de performances en termes de
reconnaissance qui aligne à l'image de
nietzsche et de the sayans pour vous
donner un peu l'importance du journal et
ça c'est le fruit d'une expérimentation
en grande échelle qui compare une
agriculture conventionnelle en orange
une agriculture biologique en verre et
en une réduction d'intrants jaune est ce
que vous regardez à la fois pour le maïs
pour le soja et pour le blé à peu près
dans les toutes les situations une
diminution une division par deux de
l'efficacité de la production agricole
quand on passe d'un modèle conventionnel
dont on pourrait discuter du bien fait à
un modèle de biologie de l'agriculture
biologique
donc ce jeu vous dire c'est qu'il faut
vraiment faire attention à l'aspect
global des choses il ya des gens qui
continuent de manger avec beaucoup de
difficultés dans le monde et je vous
parle aussi d'un exemple français
quand vous regardez cette courbe en 1960
un français en moyenne ils dépensaient
un tiers de son salaire pour se nourrir
actuellement on est entre 15 et 20 % le
risque d'une agriculture non performante
c'est la renchérissement de
l'alimentation
et quand vous regardez ce qui se passe
en ce moment sur le renchérissement des
carburants
je ne fais aucun dessin sur ce qui
pourrait se passer en termes de
renchérissement des denrées alimentaires
on a un devoir social en tant que
penseur de l'alimentation de demain on
ne peut pas exclure cet aspect humain
des choses pour des populations
qui ne sont pas des habitants des
centres villes aisée le dernier point c
est ce qu un manteau israël est vraiment
dégueulasse et vous avez un exemple d'un
monsieur qui a très longtemps officié à
la télé et qui n'a cessé de répéter que
l'alimentation est déçue elle c'était de
la merde alors c'est quelque chose qui
m'embête parce que c'est un peu mon
métier c'est pas complètement juste dans
toutes les professions avoir des moutons
noirs
nous en avons bien entendu mais je
voudrais insister sur trois aspects
importants de l'alimentation
industrielle
l'apport en sel est-ce que
l'alimentation est elle réellement
apporte plus de sel et vous comprenez
pourquoi je vous expliquerai pourquoi
j'ai fait ce choix
est-ce que l'aliment est un disque elle
amène à plus de dépenses énergétiques et
est-ce que l'alimentation industrielle
n'est pas là pour intervenir sur un
rapport de tâche partagée entre l'homme
et la femme prenons le premier point
l'alimentation comme un vecteur de
maladies alors vous avez énormément de
publication qui sont sorties dont une la
dernière celle ci qui vient d'un
chercheur de l'inra
halte aux aliments ultra transformé
alors la première question qu'est ce
qu'un aliment ultra transformé alors
vous avez l'exemple dans mon dos là vous
avez l'exemple du jambon fumé bayonne
c'est un aliment ultra transformer les
yaourts aliments transformés
on pense toujours à des plaques des
plats préparés etc mais vous avez des
aliments qui vous paraissent extrêmement
simple en gros à peu près 80% des
aliments qu'on consomme sont des
aliments ultra transformé alors j'ai
choisi celui-là parce que il est pardon
il est très riche en sel
attendez je reviens en arrière voilà il
est très riche en sel et il le présente
un inconvénient majeur en termes de
santé publique
c'est à cet inconvénient c'est les
accidents vasculaires cérébraux
ensuite depuis très longtemps qu'il ya
une relation très forte entre la
consommation de sel et les fréquences
d'action vasculaires cérébraux l'exemple
finlandais est un cas d'école
les finlandais étaient les gens qui
mangeaient dans le monde probablement le
plus salée et qui avait les fréquences
d'accidents vasculaires cérébraux les
plus importants et les finlande a choisi
d'avoir une politique extrêmement du en
terme de jeu de communication sur le sel
et en même temps en termes d'imposition
sur le sel et on s'est aperçu que au
cours des années il y avait une chute de
la consommation de sel en finlande et
que parallèlement dans la courbe
centrale vous voyez on a une diminution
de la mortalité en parallèle de la
diminution la course mancelle une
diminution de la mortalité par accidents
vasculaires cérébraux
donc oui le sel c'est important regarde
en détail des aliments industriels
on va prendre un premier cas le boulon
est ce que le bouillon de poule apporte
beaucoup trop de sel alors je vais pris
la sacro sainte règle du un descendant
des italiens la bonne règle pour cuire
des pâtes et si vous le calculer ça vous
fait 10 grammes par litre si vous prenez
les recommandations bouillon de poule va
vous arriver à 9 grammes par litre en
gros à peu près la même chose que la
règle des italiens
prenons deuxième produit qu'un produit
pour bébés mais j'ai pris une recette
d'une purée et quand vous regardez la
recette et vous faites le calcul vous
arrivez à un taux de sel deux fois
supérieur au taux de sel présent dans
l'aliment tout fait pour bébé et si vous
laissez une maman faire elle va faire sa
purée selon ses propres goûts et il ya
probablement grandes chances qu'elle
offre à son bébé une tour est deux fois
supérieur en concentration en sel à une
pure et fabriqué par un industriel
dernier produit les tomates la sauce
comme blabla aps la soupe en tomate riz
date et si vous faites le calcul et que
vous réhydrater la tomate vous obtenez
une soupe dont la teneur en sel est à
peu près deux fois inférieur aux
préférences alimentaires préférence qui
avait été déterminée dans un journal en
alors continuons le débat et partant sur
est ce que l'industrie alimentaire
consomme
plus d'énergie fossile alors pourquoi je
m'intéresse à énergie fossile tout
simplement parce que regarder
non seulement on a des belles
illustrations en ce moment sur les ronds
points
mais si vous regardez ici ce qu'on
appelle le peak oil
c'est à dire le maximum de productions
possible de pétrole la courbe en rouge
me voyez qu'on est pratiquement pick
roll c'est à dire que demain on va avoir
de moins en moins de pétrole après
demain n'aura noises au moins de gaz et
après après demain aura de moins en
moins d'uranium et moins en moins de
charbon donc à une vraie problématique
énergétique et c'est un problème majeur
et ce problème majeur il concerne pas
que les déplacements qui concerne pas
que la lumière il concerne pas que le
chauffage il concerne l'alimentation de
manière extrêmement aigu quand vous
mangez vous cuisez alors j'ai pris un
exemple d'une publication extrêmement
récente de deux de 2018 regardez
extrêmement récente qui comparé
différents facteurs et j'ai choisi
surtout ces facteurs-là de me centrer
que sur l'aspect énergétique l'usagé car
ben fossiles et qu'est ce que vous
regardez la conclusion des gens qui ont
trahi à celui qui comparaît la
fabrication d'un plat traditionnel à la
maison en bleu et par l'industrie en
orange on a beau en mal an à peu près la
même consommation d'énergie pourquoi
tout simplement parce que l'outil
industriel
regardez la moitié de l'énergie d'abord
dans les deux cas est consommée par la
production d'ingrédients alimentaires et
quand vous cuisez un aliment en inde us
tant à la maison vous avez sur
l'ensemble de l'énergie utilisée 30% qui
provient de votre méthode de cuisson
on a dû soit alimentaire l'outil est
beaucoup plus performant on arrive à 13%
ou est ce que l'industrie alimentaire
pêche dans le transport effectivement on
a 10% au lieu de 10% et surtout 14 pour
son emballage le problème de l'emballage
qu'un problème récurrent si vous prenez
maintenant la stérilisation c'est à dire
la fabrication de conserves
alors là c'est sans commune mesure si
tout le monde se met à faire des
concerts ménagères il nous faudrait
multiplier par un nombre inconsidérable
le nombre de centrales nucléaires tout
simplement parce que l'outil industriel
est ici est extrêmement performant en
terme de récupération d'énergie en
termes de barèmes de stérilisation alors
à quoi ça sert en fait de stériliser un
aliment tout simplement à huit est tombé
malade
et le grand problème de l'alimentation
c'est la stérilisation la suppression
des bactéries pathogènes et regarder
cette courbe de l'ined elle est très
intéressante
1871 monsieur pasteur explique aux
mamans qu'il faut stériliser les
biberons
terry zélés et à partir de ce moment là
bien avant l'invention de la pénicilline
vous avez une diminution d'un mortalité
infantile ce qu'il faut se rappeler
c'est que dans l'alimentation la
conserve consomment de l'énergie
elle nous permet de manger dans les
périodes hivernales elle nous permet
d'éviter de tomber malade mais ça
représente un coût énergétique
considérable et l'industrie est un moyen
d'économiser cette énergie qui sera de
plus en plus rares alors dernier point
qu'apporte l'agroalimentaire alors que
le juste vous faire une petite
comparaison entre les hommes et les
femmes en rouge le temps ménages et des
femmes en bleu tant ménages et des
hommes
vous remarquerez qui travaille beaucoup
à la maison les femmes et sur le temps
ménager des fans à tiers du temps
ménagers se passe en cuisine
quand vous regardez entre 1985 1998 et
2010 vous avez une réduction très
important du temps passé en cuisine et
quand vous comparez parallèlement à la
consommation plats préparés qui n'a
cessé de croître depuis les années 60 et
l'augmentation des conserves de légumes
et pommes de terre qui ont annoncé cette
croître la question iconoclaste m'a posé
une colle lègue une femme qui fait la
cuisine c'est de me dire est-ce que
l'agroalimentaire n'a pas été parmi les
facteurs aidant à l'accession du travail
aux femmes
petite question iconoclaste que je vous
pose ici alors en conclusion ce qui est
important de dire c'est que peut-être il
ya des problème d'échelle de temps non
seulement la vision des choses est une
vision un peu centré des centres-villes
la manière on allie des primes
alimentaires ce bien des centre-villes
un peu un peu aisée mais surtout un
prennent d'échelle de temps quand vous
comparez par exemple la politique
agricole de ministères la pac
on est en préparation pour 2027 quand
vous allez avoir pratiquement plus de
pétrole en 2070 plus de gaz en 2100 et
plus de charbon et de
matériaux fissiles en 2150 les ce
problème d'échelle
on peut leur présenter aussi par exemple
la différence entre la pac 2027 et life
farrow qui est le programme à 2050 life
à auxon problème c'est d'assurer la
sécurité de la subsistance des gens
l'approvisionnement en aliments et quand
vous regardez les différents scénarios
de coûts démographique regardait la
prévision est à 2100 quand vous regardez
la prévision de l'insee sur le
vieillissement de la population on va
passer de 10 7% à plus de 65 ans à 28% à
en regarder les prévisions de 1070 il me
semble que quand on s'occupe de près de
rénover la manière de produire des
aliments de les transformer il faut
prendre en compte d échelle beaucoup
plus grande en terme de temps regarder
de manière beaucoup plus globale la
surface de la planète pour avoir une
analyse qui soit plus juste dans la
réforme à conduire en matière agricole
en matière d'alimentation
je voudrais remercier pics à d pour la
fourniture des images gratuites et je
voudrais remercier les organisateurs de
m'avoir fait confiance
ainsi que votre présence merci à vous
[Applaudissements]